- Have a seat, ladies!
I was telling her, I was doing my cards.
And it was so funny because they,
for the show, I always write cards,
and I was like, it says the Garcia twins.
I didn't see pictures. All
it said was Garcia twins
and the Garcia twins have
been here four times.
And I was like, 'What?' I was like, 'Who?'
And you changed your
name! So I didn't know it!
And I was like, oh, the Bella
twins. I was like, so what?
Why the name change? By the
way, Hannah. Meet Hannah.
Sorry.
- I know. You're amazing, we're fans.
- This is like double ridiculous beauty.
- [Kelly] I know.
- On the couch.
- It is unfair. It is unfair. Yes!
- So Christmas right here!
- [Kelly] I know, I like
it! We're all sparkly.
We should do a number.
- I know.
- [Kelly] I'm just kidding.
Wouldn't it be funny if we just broke out?
No, but why the name
change? Curious, yeah.
- [Brie] So, Nikki and I,
we ended up leaving WWE.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, you know. WWE, when you leave,
you don't get to take your name with you,
so you have to keep it at the
ring, which was unfortunate.
But also for us, we just
really wanted our power back.
We wanted to fully own our brand.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
And going back to the
Garcia twins, it was nice.
It was like going back to our
roots. It's our legal name.
It's what we grew up with.
So it feels really good.
Very empowered.
- [Kelly] Oh, well that's nice!
- God, look how hot you are!
- [Kelly] I know. And you
were saying, I was asking,
I was asking Hannah in the
break if they had wrestling.
You had wrestling overseas.
- [Hannah] Yeah. One of my best friends,
her son Zach and Charlie
are fully obsessed
and probably would lose
their minds if they watched.
(all laughing)
- I love it. We've wrestled there a lot.
I mean, if I ever had a comeback, I mean,
I think a match right here would be.
- [Hannah] Absolutely not!
- [Brie] Yeah.
- But if you like a song
and dance, she's your girl.
- Yes! That's right, good manager. Yeah.
- Is it, was it hard leaving?
'Cause that's been a life
for y'all for so long.
- It was really hard.
It was very bittersweet.
It was one of those
things where Nikki and I,
it's like we miss the ring.
Her and I just, you know,
when you're out there,
we're like artists, you know,
it's like a blank canvas.
- Yeah.
- It's like.
- It's one of those things
where it's always a part of you.
But like it, in this book of life,
it was a chapter and a chapter
we'll always keep close
to our hearts, but now we're about to walk
into a whole new decade of 40.
- [Kelly] Yeah. I love 40 so far!
- Yeah?
- Do you?
- Forties are so good so far.
- [Nikki] Oh good
- [Brie] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yes. Well, you
actually saw me recently. I was.
- I, just that for a
second, you two are 40.
Just let, hang that for a second.
(Kelly laughing)
Crazy.
- [Kelly] Ah, okay. So
you just got married.
So how is that life? How is that?
- Oh my god, amazing.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- [Nikki] You know, and I
think, 'cause we did like.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- [Nikki] Yeah, we did
everything kind of backwards.
We had the kid first, we
went through the pandemic,
so we survived that together
and then we got married.
- I think in the South,
that's just how it goes.
- [Nikki] Yeah! And we're like okay,
we could do life together.
We've tested it for a few years.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then, we got married
and it's been amazing.
And yeah, I love him. And so.
- [Kelly] That's so awesome.
- He's the greatest.
- [Kelly] Was it. Did I hear
that your dad surprised you?
- He did!
- Yeah. What did he do?
- My dad and my mom had not been in this,
under the same roof for
what? Over 20 years.
- Oh yeah, if not longer.
- Very long time.
- So, when he surprised me.
One, just seeing my dad
in Paris was hilarious.
But, when I heard his voice,
I was like, that. 'There's
no way that's John Garcia.'
And I look and there's John Garcia!
And, it was amazing and incredible,
I hadn't seen him in a really long time.
And so, to reconnect and actually
see all my family together
since we had been 15?
- [Kelly] Wow.
- It was really incredible.
Yeah, really long time.
- It was special.
- So, let's talk about
your new show, Twin Love.
What's this about?
- [Nikki] Oh.
- [Brie] So, 10 identical
twins come to find love.
And, you know, it's crazy 'cause they,
- [Kelly] Which, are there
like a plethora of that
like hanging out?
- [Brie] Which?
- 'Cause I don't feel like
I know a lot of twins.
- I know.
- [Kelly] Identical twins.
- And they both have to be single!
- Yeah, which is hard.
- So, I know! It was a total
social dating experiment, but.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- [Nikki] Then we have
two identical houses,
the Nikki House and the Brie House.
So they don't even realize that.
That, when they're coming to us,
they think they're gonna
find love together,
and then we split them up.
Because now the experiment needs to start.
- And that's scary for twins, like.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Is it a little codependent
just because you grew up together!
- [Brie] Yes.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And you have confidence.
And then, think too,
like you're coming in,
and you're like, you're
single, you wanna impress
and then all of a sudden
we just take away that other side of you.
You gotta see every, not
only did they get very upset,
but they just kind of all
like got really small.
Like, wait, what's happening?
- [Kelly] Interesting!
- [Brie] But I will say,
what's really incredible
about the show, is not only
is it a fun dating show
that comes with that is the
drama and the messiness,
but you see these people,
these twins go on this individual journey
and they really find their individuality,
which I find is a beautiful thing 'cause,
as twins, we know that's
really hard sometimes, 'cause.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You guys are singulars.
- That's what we call you.
- Yes.
- And we're twins.
- Yeah but I bet you guys can
cause a whole load of trouble.
- [Kelly] I know!
And we missed out on it.
- Yeah.
- You! We did! You said we do.
Well, let's take a short break everybody.
Be sure to watch Twin Love on Prime Video,
as well as The Nikki & Brie Show
wherever you get your podcast.
Y'all are busy ladies.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] 'Cause you also got Barmageddon!
All right, we'll be right back.